- En apparence, c'est
un chantier parmi d'autres en
plein coeur du centre-ville.
Mais derrière les clôtures
sous la rue McGill College,
on fait un véritable plongeon
dans les entrailles de Montréal.
C'est ici, entre
la Place Ville-Marie et le
campus de l'Université McGill,
que prend forme la nouvelle
station du futur REM.
JEAN-VINCENT LACROIX, dir,
Relations médias, REM
- C'est une station
hyper stratégique pour le REM,
c'est sans doute la deuxième
plus achalandée à terme.
Elle va être à l'épicentre
de Montréal, donc ça va vraiment
venir faciliter des accès
qui par le passé se faisaient
beaucoup dans l'axe est-ouest
avec la ligne verte du métro.
CHRISTIAN DUCHARME, v.-p.,
ingénierie, CDPQ Infra
- Ça va être direct, ça va être
très facile de circuler de la
station du REM à la ligne verte.
Puis en plus, on a accès
aussi directement au réseau
sous-terrain de Montréal.
- Au nord de la station McGill,
par le tunnel du Mont-Royal,
trois minutes de train et
le REM vous fera débarquer
à l'Université de Montréal.
Creusée dans le roc, cette
partie du tunnel centenaire
est encore très solide.
Ce qui n'était pas le cas
des 200 mètres entre le sud de
la station et la gare centrale.
- Le mur central avait subi
l'effet du temps, mais surtout,
du sel de déglaçage qui était
utilisé en surface au niveau
de McGill, alors très dégradé.
Et là, l'enjeu, c'était
de venir renforcer en limitant
les impacts à la surface.
Il faut comprendre que
la technique de renforcement
aurait pu largement impacter
la rue Sainte-Catherine
- On a retenu une solution qui
est assez innovante au Québec,
qui... on l'a appelée
la voûte parapluie. C'est
une solution qui nous permet
d'intervenir par en-dessous.
- Après avoir stabilisé
l'ancienne structure,
une nouvelle voûte est
en train d'être construite
mètre par mètre.
- On a installé des arches
en acier que vous avez ici à ma
droite, donc à votre gauche.
Ces arches d'acier-là
sont appuyées sur le roc
de part et d'autres du tunnel.
Ici là, le roc va à peu près
à mi-chemin à la hauteur
du tunnel, en haut de ça,
c'est du sol meuble.
Puis on vient projeter du béton
entre chacune des arches.
On installe une voûte ou
une arche d'acier à la fois,
c'est à peu près 1,2 mètre.
On peut avancer de 1,2 mètre
à la fois, pas plus, pour
pas que le sol nous tombe
sur la tête, littéralement.
- Les travaux vont bon train
et ce tronçon central du REM,
de la gare centrale jusqu'à
la station Du Ruisseau dans
l'arrondissement Saint-Laurent,
devrait ouvrir comme prévu
à l'automne 2023. La Caisse
de dépôt n'a pas encore dit
à combien se chiffreront
les dépassements de coûts
liés aux imprévus dans
le tunnel du Mont-Royal.
- On va devoir avoir
avec des négociations, des
discussions avec l'entrepreneur,
le consortium NouvelR,
pour vraiment arriver
à statuer sur un chiffre.
- Tout porte à croire que
la facture totale du projet,
déjà passée de 6,3 à
6,9 milliard $, dépassera donc
les 7 milliards de dollars.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, M